Ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di Vita Buttata. Il tema della
puntata di oggi è "Esperienze paranormali
parte 2"
Allora, ci siamo ripresi un secondo. Che
cosa hai fatto? Tipo il simbolo della pace?
Due. Ah ok. Riprendiamo ad ascoltare i
messaggi dopo che ci siamo presi una pausa
che eravamo terrorizzati e non ce la
facevano più. Se avete visto il video della
scorsa settimana cioè capirete benissimo
perché abbiamo avuto bisogno di prendere
fiato. Siamo ancora vivi. Sì, il che è...il che è positivo
chi l'avrebbe mai detto? Direi di riprenderei
ad ascoltare i messaggi...che dici? Eh ce
tocca quindi...Oppure potremmo non lo so,
andare a giocare a qualcosa. Riguardo le
esperienze paranormali
non mi è mai capitato niente di strano
però diciamo che tutte le volte che sono
al buio o nella stanza mentre dormo
quando guardo nel buio non perché ma mi sembra
sempre sempre di vedere una sagoma, e ogni
volta devo accendere la luce. Alle volte mi fa veramente
paura
"Non mi è mai capitato niente!". Allora ti spiego
io cosa devi fare, prendi un faro della
macchina, lo metti in modalità abbagliante e
dormi di giorno, "così", sparato negli occhi
che ti brucerà la retina. A quel punto
non vedrai più nulla, ma starai meglio
Terribile cioè, se hai provato una roba del genere
sono d'accordissimo con te...se sei ancora vivo...cioè si sei ancora vivo. Vivevo con una
parente anziana che insomma gli altri
parenti mi avevano detto che faceva cose
poco chiare,
arrivo a casa anche molto tardi, vado a
letto quindi poggio la testa sul cuscino,
mi sto per addormentare e mi vengono in
mente gli amici, dico "cosa mi costa fare una
preghiera"? Quindi faccio sta breve
preghierina, un'Ave Maria insomma non
ricordo ecco, riappoggio la testa sul
cuscino, il cuscino era diventato tutto
duro, mi sbalza via dal letto, terrorizzata
ho preso e scaraventato sto cuscino. Che era
una pietra no? Si è comportata come avrei
fatto io assolutamente. Il giorno dopo viene
una mia amica, lo apre lo taglia e dentro
c'era una treccia di capelli e un cuore
rosso di stoffa. A detta sua insomma
questa parente m'aveva fatto una fattura
di morte. Tacci sua. O regà voi siete miei parenti
Io se vedo anche solo un capello vostro nel mio cuscino vi faccio un c**o così! Dio benedica i pelati
Stavo dormendo ma a un certo punto mi sveglio, io dormo sempre a pancia in giù e a un certo punto
sento che qualcuno mi sta sfilando la
coperta lentamente, io ce l'avevo sulle
spalle, me la sono ritrovata sopra il sedere.
Di istinto la prendo con le mani da
dietro a me la porto sulla schiena. Dopo
5 secondi mi succede un'altra volta
che mi si sento la coperta scivolare via, la
riprendo però me la tengo stretta con le
mani, poi sento tirare ma lasciano la
presa. Volevo girarmi ma non riuscivo. Per
giorni non riuscivo a dormire pensando a
questa cosa. Mi sono dimenticata di
dirti che non mi sono girata non tanto
perché non riuscivo ma perché avevo
paura di cosa avrei visto. Quindi non era
una paralisi del sonno diciamo?! No anche  perché
non si sarebbe potuta muovere per prendere
la coperta. Terribile! O magari c'era sua
madre, "Mi serve questa coperta", e che c***o, sono stata tutta la notte a tirartela"
No qualcuno
che veniva tirato per il vestito c'era
Ragazzi cioè vi rendete conto? Ma vi giuro, ve ne
abbiamo raccontato prima qualcuna, mio
zio che vede un quadro che si muove che fa un tic
lo dice alle sue mamme "Ma perché quel
quadro fa tic?" Loro gli dicono "E' il
dipinto di un trisavolo e aveva quel tic". Anche
parenti di cui non faremo il nome
scettici, che sono scappati di casa nel
cuore della notte
Ci stava il giamaicano nella casa (Enrico). Il giamaicano?
In tutto questo era il "barone sanguinario" era
all'interno di una casa e il giamaicano
era nell'altra?Anche perché leggevamo Harry Potter, penso che quello abbia influito
E il giamaicano chi è scusate?
No sempre io ho coniato questi nomi. Mah ne ero sicuro! Non so per quale motivo una volta stavo
dormendo nella casa tranquilla. Allora è lui,
stattene in quell'altra.... ma sento una roba tipo
come una persona velocissima che scendeva le
scale, al buio...e poi mi hanno detto "Nonna si
sveglia di notte. Ho capito...troppo veloce! Eh è diventato il giamaicano perché corrono veloce. Questa è
l'origine dei soprannomi no? La spiegazione che ci
siamo dati e che fosse la nonna il
giamaicano, che obbiettivamente è una signora agile eh. No qui abbiamo anche
una foto. Non so che cosa sia, gia mi sto c*****o sotto. Non ho visto bene ma che cos'è?
Non so se capisci o si vede bene, si vede questa persona tipo pelata che mi guarda di profilo. Non mi
ricordo neanche il dopo,  non mi ricordo niente. Mah no!
Oddio Gu, ma sembra disegnato a matita
A me sembra un brutto fotomontaggio. Ti
prego vai a vedere anche sotto Enrico
che c'è una faccia strana. Tu non hai visto niente? Io c'ho visto una faccia
Nella menzognia c'è chi ha trovato il mostro (Giulia)
Hai fatto un disegno, l'hai ritagliato e l'hai appiccicato sulla finestra. Guglielmo, c'è una testa...
Il tema è Art Attack, non è Esperienze paranormali. Questa è una foto inquieta? Sei sempre la stessa?
Un giorno in cui ero a casa di un mio
amico e stavamo un pochettino su bazookam
quel sito in cui puoi parlare con persone random
in tutto il mondo. Noi ci eravamo
accertati di essere soli a casa. Abbiamo
cominciato a parlare con due ragazzi, avevamo
visto che avevamo lo stesso giochino, e
il mio amico ha fatto uno screenshot della
schermata in cui ci mettiamo in posa
con questo giocattolo. Il mio amico pubblica
questa foto su facebook, la guardo più
attentamente e vedo che nello screenshot
dietro di noi c'era una figura che ci
guardava. Comunque adesso io allego la
foto e vi lascio giudicare. Siamo confusi
ragazzi, ora ve la mettiamo proprio in
super zoom questa cosa. Ma secondo voi
che cos'è? Se non c'era niente e c'è sto coso io...Cacchio ragazzi! No ti prego!
Questo ride per poco poi. Eh riderai poco. Un occhio alla giuria. No regà! Questa è una persona. (Enrico)
Questa è la loro porta no? E questo è un corridoio e davanti c'è un'altra porta. (Giulia)
la porta della loro stanza mi sa che è
aperta Gu. Oddio Gu
Cioè è come se passasse in un corridoio (Giulia)
Oddio santo! Oddio santo! Oddio santo! Oddio santo! Oddio santo! Oddioooo. Nooo Guglielmo!
Bene ci hai fatto c****e addosso, ufficialmente. Quando ero bambina nella mia stanza da letto c'era un quadro di
una bambina che, quando mio padre era
piccolo, era invece nella sua stanza. Mentre
dormivo lì vicino questa bambina
con questo quadro sopra il letto a un certo
punto ho cominciato a sentirla
schiarirsi la voce. Ho fatto finta di niente
Una notte due notti tre notti e la
bambina continuava. Le ho messo una
mentina sulla cornice del quadro,
lei quella notte non si è più schiarita
la voce e la mentina la mattina dopo non
c'era più, ma la cosa peggiore è che mio
padre mi ha raccontato che quando lui
era piccolo gli era successa esattamente
la stessa cosa, gli ha messo una mentina
sulla cornice del quadro e la bambina ha
smesso di schiarirsi la voce. Un bacio
La paranormalità sta nella mentina, io gli avrei dato fuoco (Giulia). Si. E se salivava?
Che poi i quadri sembra sempre che ti guardino, cioè se tu ti muovi spostano lo sguardo
Da sempre quella sensazione ( Enrico)
Però è la prima volta che sento che un quadro se magna le mentine eh. Anche questo è vero. Una sera andiamo a
tranquille, come tutte le sere, ad un certo punto io in dormiveglia inizio a sentire un peso ai piedi del letto
questo peso si sposta verso di me, dai
piedi sale, non chiedermi come ma mi
addormento ad un certo punto. Nel cuore
della notte mi chiama mia sorella
urlando, le chiedo che cosa fosse successo e mi
dice "Non ti preoccupare accendi la luce, te lo dico domani mattina". Arriva la
mattina seguente, le chiedo "Serena ma
cosa è successo?" Lei mi guarda e mi dice
"Giada io non so se dirtelo però ieri notte
c'era una ragazza chinata ai piedi del
letto. Se io ero Serena, veniva mia
sorella "Serena cos'è successo?"
Tranquilla te lo dico domani. La ragazza
com'è che stava, cioè com'è che la vi... come
ha fatto Serena a vedere la ragazza
accovacciata ai piedi del letto? E l'ha lasciata là la ragazzina? Cioè come funziona? (Enrico)
Ma quell'altra che l'ha vista, io non capisco la reazione (Giulia)
Neanche io. Non c'è del filo logico (Enrico). Io avrei avacuato l'edificio
Evacuato l'intestino. Ciao Gu ciao ospite, mia nonna naturalmente aveva mio
padre, si erano appena trasferiti in una nuova casa. Questa casa a quanto sembra, si
diceva fosse infestata, però non
ci credevano e infatti l'hanno presa pure a poco
prezzo. Mia nonna dormiva nel lettone
grande con mio padre che era piccolo.
Appena hanno spento la luce hanno
cominciato a sentire delle botte sui
muri come se ci fosse qualcuno dentro la
stanza che colpiva violentemente il muro.
Questi botte iniziamo dalla parte più
lontana della stanza e ogni volta loro
accendevano la luce e queste si fermavano
Ogni volta che loro spegnevano la luce queste
botte diventavano sempre più vicine fino a
che una botta è stata data al comodino. Da quel momento
mio nonna ha preso mio padre, non sono più
tornati e hanno venduto quella casa. Oggi
sta casa costa 20 euro. Vendiamo sta casa che veramente, costa di più andare al cinema
Ciao Gu ciao ospite, volevo raccontarvi di
questa esperienza paranormale che ha fatto
questa mia amica diversi anni fa.
Praticamente dopo aver fatto i sui
bisogni si è fatta il bidet e alla fine
si è accorta che mancava l'asciugamano
per pulirsi. Allora ad alta voce ha detto
qualcosa tipo "Cavolo dov'è finito il mio
asciugamano?", e dalla porta del bagno che non
era chiusa ma leggermente socchiusa
vola un asciugamano, che poi le prende al volo
Insomma s'asciuga e esce dal bagno per vedere
chi le aveva lanciato l'asciugamano e scopre
che lei a casa da sola.
Io pure vorrei però allora degli spiriti così a
casa mia. Perché c'è tutto sto sporco per
terra? Cioè...ma fortunata la tua amica
poteva beccare quelli che bussano nei muri. "Cavolo ho
lasciato il telecomando sul comodino".
Guarda che questa casa invece costa di più
Più inserviente invisibile. Nel cuore della notte mi sveglio con la sensazione di qualcuno che mi
respira sul viso. Sentivo propio l'alito sulle mie guance, i capelli muoversi, ma quando
apro gli occhi e mi tiro su mi accorgo
di essere sola e inizio a sentire il
letto tremare. Sentivo proprio la testiera del letto sbattere contro il muro. Dopo un po', non so bene come
riesco a riaddormentarmi.
La mattina dopo racconto la storia alla mia
coinquilina e al ragazzo della mia coinquilina che
stavano facendo colazione con me, e
mentre la racconto vedo la mia coinquilina sgranare gli
occhi e chiedermi quando fosse successo
tutto ciò. Io gli dico che appunto è
successo intorno alle 3 di notte e lei
mi dice che verso lo stesso orario il
ragazzo aveva ricevuto un messaggio al
telefono e quindi lei gli aveva chiesto di spegnere
la suoneria e lui le risponde "Non ti
preoccupare ci pensa il signore", e quando
lei gli chiede "Quale signore?" lui punta il dito
dietro di lei e fa i"Quel signore". Chi ha indicato
questo ragazzo? Ragazzi, io non ho capito niente ma
mi ha terrorizzato questo racconto. Non ce la faccio più! Il matto sembra il ragazzo in questa storia. Si, mollalo!
Quel signore! Ma io t'ammazzo! Sicuramente era in'una sorta di dormiveglia. Ti prego arriviamo alla fine, sta
diventando...sta diventando estenuante.
Spero di essere ancora in tempo...purtroppo si...
per raccontarvi la mia macabra esperienza
paranormale. Quattro o cinque anni fa sono andata in
campeggio con la mia migliore amica, la
sua famiglia e mia madre. La notte dormivano
nel loro camper e praticamente l'ultima
notte, mentre stavamo dormendo, mi sveglio
mi giro e davanti a me trovo a fianco al
letto una ragazza in piedi che mi fissa
Sveglio la mia amica, dormiva affianco a me, però lei non si è svegliata. Mi sono
fatta coraggio, mi sono rigirata di
nuovo e la ragazza era ancora lì. Nono!
Stavolta ai piedi del letto, seduta, sempre rivolta
verso di me che mi fissava. Ho dormito
per un mese nel letto di mia mamma. Io l'amica mia la svegliavo a pugni
se non si svegliava. Ma stiamo scherzando! Io sapete non so
se a quel punto me la sarei giocata con "Cosa vuoi?"
Mi giro mi rigiro e ci sei di nuovo...eh ci parli (Enrico)
Ah ci fai pure amicizia quindi?! No vabbè nel senso cioè...
Eh vabbè là nel momento vi ci voglio vedé a dì "Cosa vuoi?"
Però vabbè faccio prima a tirà un calcio all'amica mia. Magari non è che dici "Cosa vuoi?", fai "Cota vuoii?"
Io non ce la faccio più ragazzi, io mi sembro Donatello, Michelangelo e Raffaello delle Tartarughe Ninja perché
ho un guscio di pelle d'oca dietro. Non ce la faccio più!
Ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine di questa
puntata. Non se ne può più ragazzi!
Io questo tema non lo voglio
fare mai più nella vita, mai più in
tutta la mia vita, io vi ringrazio per
averli condivisi ma soprattutto vi
ringrazio per aver avuto la forza di
sopravvivere ad alcuni di questi
racconti. Mamma mia! Avete tirato fuori roba di spessore. Di spessore.
Ringrazio anche te Gianmarco per avermi...Grazie, grazie a voi...Ringrazio anche in realtà Enrico e Giulia che ci
hanno fatto compagnia, qui di lato tipo
giuria...presenze (Enrico)... si, delle nostre presenze
che non avete potuto vedere. Che dire, iscrivetevi a questo canale se vi è piaciuto
attivate la notifica per non perdere
nessun video e che dire, ci vediamo alla
prossima settimana con un tema molto
più leggero, spero. Ciao. Ciao